you can go here we're live hey so the
key the key to going live it to not do
anything to your say alright hold on
we're just gonna update this I'm gonna
make a public for everyone yay Guardians
3 Gog 3 is alma on the livestream before
we make it public so I was just watching
this we can't we can't fix the thumbnail
[Laughter]
we can't fix something is we can't over
anyone who is this is all private right
now so you're not on the livestream this
is all like great great news for you
guys
this good alright so let's go back to
here and then we'll make it public show
on the show I think we're public inquiry
I think it's working now let's get some
people in this here chatroom ok I think
we're actually we got it working
yay people to show up now you people we
got two people hell yeah look oh we're
actually lying people tell it please
confirm that you can see us and hear us
please confirm that for us we have no
idea how long's works so six people here
so far please leave a say something in
the chat please say something kind yes
we can [ __ ] yeah time man only third
time's a shot
all right we're just gonna wait for some
people to come in here and then we're
gonna get this show on the road people
confirmed we knew here what's up yes
she's always a joy we finally get this
working technical
successes I'm so happy right now thank
you guys for being here thank you for
being patient and John get them while I
update some of this stuff in the
description box guys how you doing it's
nice to see legends that's very kind of
you I think we're maybe like myths at
this point that someday will reach
legendary status you can never break the
chain you guys are good you gave me like
a medley of things Macklin butcher
that's a cool name how's it going to you
we're gonna talk about James Gunn today
guys the news just progressed like the
most random news story of the day at
first when you notified me something had
happened I thought there was like a
problem like I thought but I couldn't
believe it man I couldn't believe it
don't we're going to talk about all this
in the second or just wait for some more
people to pile in for the people who
have been Reno defied that we are here
take Heath Frick these fellows up I
don't know what that means Anthony
Aguilar but thanks for contributing a
thought all right Anthony we got 46
people in here so we'll wait till we're
like close to 70 close to 10,000 people
then we'll start talking yes let me just
share this on the YouTube community page
right now turn of the gun that's gonna
be the subtitle yeah and then every
supporting character is going to be
played by one of James Gunn's many
brothers but in this on the community
page guys thanks for being patient I
don't know why the YouTube is so funky
with us with all these things and then I
put this on patreon to let people know
if I mean we were already would we've
just been disappointed yet cuz like we
were disappointed that he got taken off
the project you know and so yeah but I
wouldn't have been like nasty about
somebody else taking the reins
necessarily if that makes any sense
James Gunn is the first director in the
MCU to direct an entire trilogy and
that's true no snow come on looky there
so guys although not the first director
or set of directors to do three movie
all right now that we got 90
problems Oh 104 people awesome hell yeah
alright well guys let's hop into this
now shall we cuz um yeah yesterday John
I over up was up around like like 350
Europe for summer there yeah yes ten
minute difference there and I didn't
really catch up absolutely so so today I
was like you know what we we edited a
lot after all that Avenger stuff and
then moved on to and then did a bunch of
stuff for patreon whatever and now and
then I'm like you well today we'll take
it a little bit easy but then this news
drops and I was like okay never mind if
I see either one of us seemed a little
bit tired that's why because James Gunn
is back he is directing guardians of the
galaxy 3 as reported by deadline I love
this Disney did all the right things had
all the right things they fired him for
being a pervert and then they hired him
back for firing him for being a pervert
they did it all you know they got their
cake and they they got seated -
basically they got to respond and now
everyone's happy
the funny thing about the deadline
reporters they were saying they didn't
actually they didn't consider any
directors and apparently a few months
ago this was already established that
this is what they were gonna be doing so
this is this this didn't seem like it
was a permanent firing at all and maybe
that's maybe they like felt like they
needed to do a temporary kind of
wondering like what were the mechanics -
they they temporarily feel like they
needed a fire James Gunn just so they
could look a little bit good with some
of the people who were mad at the time
because apparently all those things
about approaching techo IT there Adam
McKay we're all just false rumors and
the Marvel never actually considered
getting someone and it would line up
with everything else of everyone being
like there's no way direct this pretty
kidding no way I would direct this movie
take James place yeah it was gonna have
Alan Smithee direct to sue but
apparently he's also doing Suicide Squad
- and then immediately after he's
hopping on to this I can a Matt I can't
imagine the level of pressure
James Gunn must be under now I know he's
the he's the first crossover DC Marvel
character and it's like okay there was
there's all this talk about oh can he
save Suicide Squad with his rendition
everyone has a lot of faith in him we're
doing that and then Guardians the it's a
man to have him back is making me sort
of wonder what if both of these movies
happen to suck what if he does a
terrible job on both of them are all
like all this hype about James Gunn was
so not worth it he's not worse than the
first Suicide Squad man I hope it's good
because I'm part of the camp that wasn't
a big fan of guardians of the galaxy vol
2 you're gonna say Sue's like really
yeah but I will say this there is no one
else I would rather direct Guardians 3
then James Gunn despite my own personal
opinions that I had towards Guardians 2
I still feel like well now the only
person who should be doing this is James
Gunn yeah I mean because he's made
guardians at least the film's very much
in his voice and of his Sensibility and
it's true what they say I mean like if
you look at how the MCU has grown
especially since guardians like his
input is very evident and so yeah it
seems like especially with the way he
was removed like I would imagine
especially with that script being his
yeah the only person who can really do
it the way they need them to do his good
and yeah we did a whole video about the
day he was fired and I do think that
there should have been a conversation
about his firing as opposed to just
firing him so we're that's how my joke
of like Disney alright recovery every
corner of this let's fire and then bring
him back we look good wait awhile aslam
maybe let somebody else get fired from a
gig for med this is an interesting part
of his movement right here
hey thanks a renin Auto what what have
they hired him suddenly I don't I don't
think it was a sudden hiring dude I
according to the deadline reports that
it wasn't and we've got to keep in mind
too this is not confirmed by Disney or
James Gunn I'm sure we'll probably get
something later on today but for
deadlines saying this is definitely not
true
Ted lighted Hollywood Reporter to come
out about this
usually it's true usually have they been
wrong in the past sure but I have you
know like to me to reinstate him was a
surprise but I was here editing
something and I told out like what did
you hear about this something is part of
it my feet did somebody take divinity or
in-game video yeah exactly so yeah I
don't think it was a sudden hiring it
seems usually with things like this
there is a talk of it in advance when a
casting or anything like that there's a
while before they decide to announce it
there are millions and millions of
dollars on the line you can bet they
thought this through it was that Jake
from patreon he said been watching the
rejects before but never subscribed
after watching you on movie fights and
your W 2018 best moves reaction video I
had this thanks man but James Gunn did
tweet about it what well I got people
here that here saying that he did tweet
about it shouts out to Red Hood 23 [ __ ]
back on Twitter
firing me oh [ __ ] guys my reaction right
here oh I am tremendously grateful to
every person out there who has supported
me over the past few months this is 20
minutes ago
I am always learning and will continue
to work it be the best human being I
could be I deeply appreciate Disney's
decision and I'm excited to continue
making films that investigate the ties
of love that bind us all a habit and
continue to be incredibly humbled by our
love and support from the bottom of my
heart thank you love to you all twenty
minutes ago
damn this is like so surprising of a day
and also not surprising the information
so it's like such a wide variety of
emotions I'm going through on this
matter right now you just did I like for
a corporation to go back on something
like this for Disney is shocking to me
it's so shocking Disney is arguably the
most ironclad conglomerate you know we
have right now in terms of just how much
sway and confidence they have in
so like yeah I really am fast that I
would love to have been able to hear
some of those conversations go down yes
Tiffany Holman just said with gun coming
back I was just about to bring this up
Thank You Tiffany I was just about race
up with gun coming back to you soon he
said think the entire cast is coming
back Dave Bautista said he wasn't coming
back if gun wasn't coming back yeah I
was just about to sob all about deal
yeah we don't just make him a joke
character this yeah no of course the
cast is coming back they all signed that
letter they were all very much in
support and they were all very much
disheartened by James gun being fired
know if you guys saw that letter that
went out they all the whole cast signed
it so absolutely I guess that also makes
sense as to why Sean gun was talking
even more positively about you know
we're still Guardians three without
saying that James got his brothers
returning but it was ruin my
relationship with my brother we're still
making them I feel like they were
segwaying into it yeah possibly like III
do believe that it would be a few months
that they had known about this and they
were slowly like okay there's a lot of
backlash we're getting four fire here we
don't have a movie anymore it was but
also you know dude he handled the
situation great I think that's the
biggest takeaway from me is yeah there's
the way he took this every step of the
way because we've seen other people not
be so gracious you know and his ability
to just accept it take it on the chin
and yeah not be ugly in any way about it
yeah speaks volumes and that's really
like in the time now where we have to
deal with this so much more and we got
various reasons for celebrities coming
under fire for things I think you can
tell a lot especially in the
conversation about when is it time for
people to come back or whatever to get a
second chance you can tell a lot about
the answer to that by how they handled
these things and I thought James Gunn is
one of the few who has really done a
graceful job at that yeah that the post
effective after the the hope the whole
firing was he handled that in the in the
right way yeah I'm not proud that I did
that yeah
he had no like attack against Disney or
anything like that you know he just he
strictly owned up and they were already
saying there but I feel like they were
like when you look back on it
there were John I haven't had a moment
to talk about this be enough to solve it
there were like trickles of things of
maybe you know like oh no we're still
using James gun strip don't worry about
that we're still using James gun strip
no we don't have another director coming
in don't worry about that don't worry
about that and now you know why are
people so we were saying like Quinta
choco saying like guys the hint was in
the bright burn hmm was it was it is it
was there like a DVD copy of guardians
three lying around with a giant brought
to you by James Gunn sticker on the
front Oh awesome Evans thank you so much
and yes if you guys didn't read you guys
are just hopping in we did read the
Twitter from James gum where he is
confirming that man it's confirmed
that's [ __ ] crazy I proved this I'm
like well wait hold on maybe I shouldn't
get too excited because it's not being
confirmed
and also is supposedly in five days
going off Mike P 15 a comment here thank
you buddy
perfect timing since the Disney Fox
deals around the corner don't you think
yes it is
with supposedly that deal is officially
happening in five days from now yeah
the merger so that that is good timing
I'm not sure how much I have this James
Gunn thing really it's perfect when that
is the reason for it I mean considering
that he has a Sony Pictures superhero
spin with bright burn coming out that
he's actively involved in on the
producer side of the gun families all
involved in there and then with WB and
DC he's got some aside squad to coming
out and then with Marvel he's good he's
like it's gonna be the king of the
superhero genre Sam yeah yeah yeah it
really is gonna be with the two Titans
and on his own independent beat like and
that's fascinating to me too and I think
that somebody brought that up earlier I
think that is a lot of pressure for him
because yeah - it's not only just about
those movies said he has a lot of well
yeah but it's not just about those two
movies being good then it's like the u
diam ajan there's so much like
of conscious back and forth you can do
about like well is he gonna do a worse
job for the GC one versus the Marvel one
or is he gonna like you know know if
anything I think the idea of him doing
both a DC movie and a Marvel movie can
help simmer down a lot of the
competition of Marvel versing DC oh yeah
imagine if he's a guy who's hopping back
and forth between both companies as
opposed to making it like one thing that
really stood out to me in this whole you
know of the political arguments of you
know brie Larson with Captain Marvel or
the people and then Zachary Levi putting
out that video on social media of guys
stop trying to pit Captain Marvel and
Shazam against each other they could go
watch both movies like you know I love
that and then so having but having a
director that create the the creative
visionary guy behind the camera for both
like major properties in both of the you
know DC and Marvel world I feel like can
help blend that instead of putting them
against each other of course so they'll
still be pitted against each other but I
feel like it'll simmer it down a little
bit oh yeah especially if he continues
to work with DC after Suicide Squad -
yeah yeah I'm more men just as a
whimsical thing like after both movies
are out like if for some reason I would
be fascinated I hope he writes a book
someday about what it's like especially
at this time to work with two wildly
different Studios on a similar kind of
movie because yeah you can tell that
Marvel and Warner DC run their shows
very differently yeah it's like that's a
fascinating thing to me that I would
love to hear more about from his his
side you know it's fascinating to me
especially to how a guy whose things
outside of filmmaking so arguably his
personal life has brought it's like
we're very much aware of the James Gunn
the person now and not just the work in
front of the camera like I don't really
I'm not really aware of like the Russo
brothers who they like their personal
life or anything like that that's been
put in front of the media so many
pedophilic today I'm just aware of their
hey they during all those Avengers
movies it's not you know whereas James
Caan has this unique thing where we're
aware of him but he's still done such a
good job at at keeping his personal life
for the most part pretty private yeah in
this whole debacle he's done a really
good job so we could so he can still
look at just
framework of like Suicide Squad - and
guardians 3 without thinking about James
Gunn the person yeah you know which is a
very impressive thing to do in the midst
of all this where you're not I feel like
I can still watch those movies stop
being hyper aware of James Gunn the
person you know yeah yeah shouts out for
some super chats also Ally cold Kelly
David Waterhouse is here oh damn Jani
Hoffman again Nick be ill Soto six thank
you guys
ally Nellie yeah it is there's some
great news man Marvel's the marvel week
for the week of unexpected [ __ ] from
Marvel yeah that's what this week has
been got an in-game transected
controversy yeah expected trailer even
uh shangri-la Q point called shangri-la
the the dammit you guys would know that
what's the name of the new Marvel movie
that's been announced to come through
character I don't know it o Shang Shazam
someone's gonna put it in there the
original [ __ ] someone someone will drop
it in there a second and and also it was
cold Kelly the prodigal gun returns yes
he does Tiffany Holman you guys should
do more live streams thanks Tiffany ah
tiffany tiffany every time I hear that
name Tiffany I think about that bit in a
and Ted yeah Jenny Lee hey my girlfriend
goes by forever Tiffany's so she is not
a [ __ ] I mean maybe on our downtown
okay there Nick be just glad that he got
a second chance and that's probably the
biggest takeaway ed Nick be here like
that he's getting a second like
redemptions real in corporate world that
shocks me the most that he's getting a
second chance that's why I'm saying this
is the best [ __ ] card it's the galaxy
movie that's ever been done now in court
well I don't know if I fully agree or
not I mean I do I am shocked that Disney
would backtrack but in corporate world I
also think to myself well these are
multi-million dollar investments that
are making and with Marvel especially
they have a lot of foresight so if you
mess up one installment that probably
messes up the rest of the installments
and
thinking uh if James Gunn really is like
an integral part of the Guardians series
it almost seems like it would be very
cost-effective to bring him back and
also within the eyes of the fans because
now you were losing the cast you're
losing people's favor in some ways as a
business move I think this is a smart
business move for them from a cynical
side like I feel like in a lot of
situations Pacific live another shades
of grey and while we're talking about
here I feel like in a business
perspective though of image yeah
like we've we know we stand by our
decision here and then to be willing to
go maybe we shouldn't have made that
decision with this individual says a lot
for them and just makes Disney look a
little bit better but in all fairness up
I think John's actually a lot more right
than I am this is gray in both of what
we're seeing the face of the come yes we
made a lapse in judgment but I also
think too that there for them I they get
to save some face because of his
behavior yeah theater have not been ugly
about this so I think even if some
people are still outraged or whatever I
think most people are like seems all
right after like you know Kevin Hart
didn't demonstrate the same behavior and
thus didn't host the Oscars you know
yeah we've had other examples too ago
that was worse and David Davis
indulgence hey guys much love David
Waterhouse I hope you're doing better
buddy I haven't heard from you on
patreon or in a while but I hope you're
doing better right now I need to catch
up with you dude and then ill Soto six
love your stuff thanks ill Soto we love
your stuff - yeah I'm a big fan you got
a wife an ill Mike DP of 15 who says he
works on both sides crossover akin
happening fan sent up although that
would that that is a cool thing to think
about those I'll give me that that's a
that's a really cool thing to to
fantasize about Hema everything he might
have a point cuz that does pretty it's
light like an inch closer than the
possibility of that happening you know
everybody got a streaming service now
there
so many more ways to get these things
out we could get a little weird
Elseworlds time vortex you know bizarro
thing happening where we get some
crossovers down the line I feel like I
don't know the thing is as much as there
is a separation between Marvel oh do you
see if they did crossover and some
capacity I feel like people would go
nuts and they would make a lot of money
guys well I think that's actually a
funny theory to Chris 1306 the idea that
he maybe was never fired to begin with
and they just did this like I don't
necessarily believe that but I think it
is kind of funny to think about because
they've said like we've been talking
about this for a couple months now about
bringing it back so I'm like who you
know like what this does work in their
favor because now more than ever there
is more height for guardians of the
galaxy 3 oh yeah yeah they this without
any firing without any of this happening
there wouldn't be as much anticipation
now everyone wants to know is this gonna
be good teaser trailers just gonna be
James guys literally just gonna be him
being like I'm directing this again
I'm bad you know may it's gonna be the
decimation effect of his tweets it's
gonna be so freakin cool what happened
in news like oh you didn't hear about
New Zealand no oh God do you know it's
terrible what happened yesterday not as
I got a very serious no like I'm finding
out about so much news this week I had
no like about like 40 people were killed
at a church Oh God oh forget what it's
called a church Christ Church Oh 49 died
Oh attack on mosques in Christian yeah
this [ __ ] nuts man people went there
like seriously say I was looking a lot
whele this is part of what was keeping
us up last night we were love that on
Twitter
my girlfriend show me about it I was
usually Miss situations like this you
can find a spot to donate some money to
if you guys don't know about this this
is like such a change in conversation
here but I feel like I would like to
talk about it sure but yeah 49 dead
a terror attack basically these people
came in live-streaming they said some
[ __ ] about like subscribe to PewDiePie
and they killed a [ __ ] they kill a lot
of [ __ ] people it's terrible so like
a lot of this was on camera oh and
there's even the 49er report of death
there's more people who were injured so
like late last night I was on my phone I
was trying to look up like working
usually for things like this you can
find a place to donate to help out yeah
yeah no this is terrible prayers to
their families and everything cuz this
is really I I did not expect this to
come up in the livestream I don't know
you didn't know about it I and I don't
want to make this about PewDiePie I
don't think it's I think to blame it on
PewDiePie is [ __ ] ridiculous these
people are well yeah it's not somebody
co-opted his name unless he called from
like a half two things I'm generally not
a fan of PewDiePie generally speaking
but I also won't go here and go this is
his fault yeah I don't like PewDiePie
that much about to be like yeah you're
responsible for terrorism it's
disgusting and don't view the videos
that's just given them what they want
yeah I would also say that I would also
say you know if you guys can find a way
to go donate or help out or you know
prayers to the people and you'd like to
hear about this in New Zealand of all
places I've always associated New
Zealand as a place where there's like
let's be like the kind people come from
yeah
so for this to happen there's I don't
know the details of the shooters or
anything like that but man as some
that's stomach-turning don't watch don't
watch geeks and gamers yes on that
situation to geeks and gamers is that to
who they were
I've heard that name lately the yeah
that's what I've heard about and that
night I don't know no I was I'm not
saying don't watch it was like honestly
don't know enough information about that
situation with the geeks and gamers but
that that's that's one thing that I've
heard of several people say I need to
read more into that research where I can
form a real opinion about that situation
I need to like look more into that ya
know there's some terrible things here
I'm gonna read
more later on it tonight because yeah I
heard about this like midnight last
night did you hear about the celebrities
getting stung and arrested for like
bribing university crazy oh yeah prayers
to them to all the families people who
they're people who are survived but are
injured right now crazy [ __ ] so ya know
we did hear about it we'll move on
normally for something like this is
probably best to address it at the top
as someone did bring it up yeah if you
haven't heard about it go look up the
situation if you do feel compelled to
help or done it in some way if there is
an option to do so I couldn't find one
last night but go ahead and find a way
to do that but yeah we'll move on from
there this is in my mind this isn't this
is really at this has been on my mind
for the most part so do keep it bring
some awareness to yourself and go look
it up but anyway how do we transition to
this to a difference who decided they
may be nicer topic I don't know there's
something about reading it in the in the
kana like reading about it I was like
not people don't know about this I feel
like they should yeah is a aware of the
world is mics you would like to escape
it like we live in America or they're
shootings like every [ __ ] week now
and hear about this in a New Zealand was
like goddamn this insane me you know are
you guys are ahead of us but anyway how
do we transition let's just take take
any random question here and well we'll
transition out of this QA ask me
anything ask anything all right you
dudes are awesome agent super agro are
you named after the Ben Affleck film he
will he says he's been widening since he
was 11
how old do you know 12 telling you love
you know shouldn't be watching us then
again you guys probably watch were stuff
yeah probably you probably watch
pornography I love it okay well now that
we talked about our enthusiasm for James
Gunn returning there's someone here says
I have no idea why people like that
James Gunn is back worst decision ever
made by Marvel horrible and discussing
let's say I'm curious to hear the the
counter I'm curious near the counter
to our thoughts I feel like it's only
fair to open up the discussion to both
so unload in here if you'd like to I'm
sure you guys will go back and forth for
the most part yeah aw somebody retracted
a message I've never seen that before is
there behind the scenes of The Avengers
trailer skin on your patreon there's a
bloopers reel like the shot where I have
my favorite bloopers the moment where
the shot I don't know if he hasn't seen
her Avengers endgame sketch but when I
run into the bathroom and I and I
immediately like a split second later
the way we did that shot was really fun
so cut dude this person's talking about
April is packed with Shazam and game
attack off that in Game of Thrones Greg
if you could watch bone what would it be
now here's the funny part I'm trying to
watch it all oh that's the hard part
about this thing I'm trying to watch it
all because I heard one punch man is
even coming back and I'm I'm only on the
sixth I'm only on the seventh episode of
season one I watch it weekly on patreon
with reaction highlights include and
attack on Titans coming back Game of
Thrones Cobra Kai there's so many things
coming April just already with the movie
and I'm in the process to try and move
as well so I'm just like well there's
just April's gonna be just a [ __ ]
crazy month for me yeah I'm already
pretty overwhelmed by the thought of it
so I'm trying to take it one day at a
time right now but I'll do it one thing
to prepare at the time yeah and then
next week I got movie fights and we're
at the free for all for the Schmo down
so I'm like they try to fill my mind
with as much and trying to be creative
to it maybe I think it's catch for the
end game trailer for the end game review
so a lot going on Mike PDF 15 besides
predator alien and avatar what else are
you excited for with the Disney Fox deal
the x-men crossing over into it I'm
trying to I do have an idea and I told
John about it recently and and also I
want to make a separate video for it and
I was actually on the phone with Andrew
who was in our end game trailer reaction
yesterday I was on the phone with him
and I was telling him like here's
exactly how I think you can introduce
x-men into the MCU
exact because there's been a lot of
debate about you know with with the
x-men world it's very different from the
MCU world just generally speaking even
in comic book world format because you
know you got like Spider Man and Captain
America and their heroes but then you
got this one side we're like half the
population all have powers everyone
[ __ ] hates them you know the x-men to
me feels more like Marvel Netflix than
Marvel cinema
you know fairy I that's a fair point but
I thought of like okay well how because
the people have brought that up as that
would drastically change it's not like
you like you can introduce the Fantastic
Four no problem
into the MCU that'd be no problem but
introducing x-men changes not just the
superhero landscape but the entire world
that they live in yeah there's grass
with that yeah yeah and I thought of a
way they can successfully do it where
they can make the MCU evolve so I don't
know maybe a movie if I got a chance the
Pichet actually because around the time
I go on movie fights is around the time
the Disney Fox murder will happen so
maybe I maybe an opportunity to go
here's how you because that would be a
cool way to do it yeah so I'm excited
about that thanks for the question and
hopefully I can make a video about it
beforehand totes do you have any
theories about what could happen in vol
3 all them die except for Drax yeah and
then ego comes back and he's the main
character comes back everyone dies James
Gunn walks in frame puts his arm around
Drax and goes I'm glad you stood by my
side the entire time publicly though
sign that letter you you went the extra
you were willing to leave Marvel huge
baggy trailer reaction perhaps Emily
Blunt and John Krasinski in the
Fantastic Four sure I that's a popular
throw throw out there and I and I think
it would work it does yeah it doesn't
make me like oh [ __ ] yeah but you know
I'm assuming you mean rewritten
simple girl not not a Johnny Storm
yeah and that was work no because they
were yeah they're related in selling
[ __ ] weird would it be what I would
hope for cuz the big rumor that's going
around and it just seems likely as a cap
will die in endgame they're even kind of
building it up that he will die
you know submit imagery that they're
showing it just looks like he's gonna
die but what if it's just Brody
[Laughter]
the official send-off beloved side
character so but I thought it would be
so cool if you get Captain America to
interact with the new Johnny Storm you a
really fun thing that would be very fun
Tony will die and live through the
spider load his intelligence and he'll
be the new Jarvis for spider-man Josh I
would like to go more to my x-men
theories but I'm saving that I need to
flush it out a little bit time vortex is
Roger Rabbit sequel heck yeah the thing
I'm curious about about this Disney Fox
merger is what happens to stuff like Fox
Searchlight like what happens to the
other wings we don't notice
where does West set is Wes Anderson get
to make like a low-budget Marvel movie
now how cool would that be independent
stop-motion animation
everyone's like Edward Norton and Jason
Schwartzman Jeff great fantastic four
characters when I okay what I really
want honestly on a separate note what I
what I really want from the Disney Fox
merger more than the Fantastic Four is
actually Doctor Doom I want dr. new to
be introduced he's a fantastic bill and
I heard that they you know that there's
some there's kind of a weird Q&A that
was going on and was like wait a minute
are they or are they not or you don't
listen but I think having a Doctor Doom
in the MCU will be awesome and you know
I feel like after her Thanos - you need
a you need an iconic villain to really
make a cool big-screen debut this is
like topic
top-1 and tannaz leaves them with a very
big mantle to keep filling now because
like marbles villain problem has are
largely leased by Thanos been kind of
solved for the moment so yes they're
gonna have to figure something out
let's see here okay mic'd it says I
think Tony authorities ERV to beat
Thanos so that everyone besides his
daughter's what do you guys think I
think nebula deserves it the lighter man
deserves it for us for the people I
think I think star lore will come in and
do it
I think final blow Tony and Thor will
it'll be like an alley oop like they'll
be on top of it and then star wars gonna
deliver like the crippling blow he's
gonna like laser blast him in the face
or something like that I'm not gonna
make the same mistake twice yeah yeah
the master Bruce Reed Richards should be
an end game end credits as cool as ever
being as cool as people want like cousin
x-men tease they already have their end
game there they have their post credit
scene established it's already done you
know Captain Marvel - it's something
it's either for spider-man far from home
or it's them one after spider-man far
from home which I forgot what it is but
it's it's something that's gonna set up
for that it's like that - here just
commented mr. stark I feel so good I
really hope he says that upon being on
destination oh dude hey I'm with this
Fox merger maybe we can get some of
those crazy like I know DC characters
have fought alien in the past so let's
get some more like dude how cool would
it be to watch like not Iron Man but
like I don't know Scarlet Witch or
something III actually some people were
been talking about wanting Adam warlock
back in here and as I mentioned him the
end game trailer - breakdown video I
reread the last half of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book and Adam warlock is
is a savior you know is ultimately the
reason the main reason we beat Thanos in
the comic book right the thing though
with Adam warlock especially now that
you have Captain Marvel in here
presumably Thanos will lose an endgame
then I feel like if you bring Adam
warlock in here
it's like you got Captain Marvel and
Adam warlock like these two super beings
like impossible to defeat we need the
threat level we need a threat level so
I'm not opposed to Adam warlock
eventually coming in but I think right
now I don't think it would be wise
timing for here and in fact I'm also
hoping they don't kill off that house in
here you know they follow the gauntlet
comic book at all or any of the haven't
read the other ones but they make him an
Avenger there's a way to win without
killing him off that's all I'll say
and I now I'm think that would be a good
DC Lane is talking about Adam warlock
was teasing guardians to but James Gunn
also said like that was just a fun TC
had five mid and post credits scenes you
know they're not all meant to be
something for like the big future I kind
of take the guardians credit scenes like
the Deadpool credit scenes I'm like
you're just having a good time yeah
that's right DC big Oh so yeah he came
in 40 minutes late here but yes he is
back good glad Yuri's eyes yes yes yes
all right guys we got a we got quite a
bit of things to get to so this is a
five minute heads-up alright five minute
heads up and then we're gonna call it a
day you know Howard the Duck movie Anna
Kendrick squirrel harder Lovejoy put
Howard the Duck movie and retracted his
message oh gotta have more confidence
what you say somebody put out Anna
Kendrick for Squirrel Girl I thought I
heard that they were gonna do that
before long but I don't know Sam is
shocked did you guys already talked
about the quantum realm suits in the new
infinity war trailer yeah it's actually
the end game trailer and also you gotta
go to our end game breakdown video
because we did talk a lot about that in
there which I'm surprised there are just
a few breakdown videos and you know like
when I when we saw those suits it's like
yeah that's like a lot what the the hank
pym suit that he wore at the end of
ant-man and the wasp and it would make
the most sense because we've been
hearing all about quantum realms you
know yeah Burton's here and a lot of
people are more reference seeing I love
you more referencing and one of the
Avengers costumes that they've seen like
Gamora we're in the comics but like well
in terms of the movies
and where they're headed in the mission
they're on wouldn't it make more sense
with like not a lot people bringing up
the quantum realm suit so I'm like but
this makes the most sense it's a quantum
realm suits right yeah most reliable way
to solve this problem and especially if
this is where they're teaming up you
know Tiffany home and Deb Deadpool I'm
more excited for MCU characters to
interact in a Deadpool movie than I am
at the idea of Deadpool being another
you MCU movies if that makes sense
oh yeah like on Deadpool surface where
that's the most fun because I feel like
anywhere else it's gonna be like kind of
watered-down Deadpool
yeah you know or Deadpool on a leash
which just isn't as fun
Johnson Yara's asking one's MHA going on
patreon well I finished the reaction
highlights edit last night the stream
along will be uploading after this so
around 3 p.m. Pacific Standard Time it
will be published on our patreon the
next episode damn good reaction I'll
tell you that's a good episode yeah I
was we had a lot of lot of emotion in
that I am here yeah no remember the
show's foster lovin from like a lot of
you guys who are here had and watched
our breakdown video where we highly talk
about like a lobbies are manipulated
here's what we think could be
manipulated like I'm even under the
impression that maybe Tony and nebula
might not even be in like if they're not
in the suits in that shot I wouldn't be
surprised because they know people are
gonna try to break down this [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] dude zeroing out you came
out a little late but thanks for burner
dude James Gunn is back is alright in
the universe I gotta go waiting for
Captain Marvel that just wants it well
that's if you could say hi with us with
a twenty dollar super chat every single
time I will I will greet you with arms
wide open
we don't yeah hi alright see you buddy
that's that's a great way it's a great
way to have an established friendship
here yeah two and a half minute warning
people then we're gonna log off I
actually have come to enjoy that about
the Marvel trailers now like as much as
there are things to scoff about about
misinformation and trailers like
especially I don't think it worked
entirely in Captain Marvel's favor but I
actually came out of that movie
appreciating how much they didn't show
and then yeah after infinity where I'm
like well you know this fee
like a shot that could have like easily
fit here and so in that way now I kind
of find Marvel's misinformation as part
of the fun because they know what to
show you to Elise thus far to where you
don't go in the movie and be like well I
was misled you know oh she ain't cheap
are they making an Iron Fist movie yeah
with with - Jones verified he just puts
out a tweet about everyone's love and
support
no Shan Shan Qi is the Kung Fu character
that are adapting for the big screen in
the Marvel yeah I'm hoping they get a
white actor that one that one better
better have the best hand-to-hand fight
scenes we've ever seen in the MCU better
it's got to be better than daredevil
dick Gareth Evans - director yeah hands
down yeah well no they already have a
director slated for it I forgot who it
was but let's look him up and then we'll
probably call this event gtfo shang-chi
director is destined Daniel Krypton
let's look up at Stratos what are we
thinking about him live-action American
my hero academia movie very wary eye
it's gonna be a long time before I'm
optimistic about although I liked Aleta
but yeah I've also heard the full metal
alchemist movie leaves a lot to be
desired so I would hold off this guy
hasn't I mean he's cool isn't he's an
Asian director that I can't really see
anything he's done this action based or
something but then again it doesn't
surprise me with Marvel he's done a lot
of documentaries and drama films so
imagine a phobia v there will be a fine
movie at the least but it's got to be
the best directed hand-to-hand combat
that we've ever seen because of for the
fact that daredevil is the staple of MCS
and like that's cool but come on the
movies have to match have to keep up
with the TV show I mean we love powers
and gadgets but sometimes just a great
fight with beautiful ingenuity is all
you need
alright guys well we're gonna we're
gonna log off right now but hey thank
you - hey Andrew Hayes you showed up a
little - Andrew
eight my favorite attack on Titan
character is Levi he's my favorite tag
on tire kickers won't put that out their
minds Aaron because I've heard all the
names over your shoulder but I don't
know what any of those characters are
and if anyone's do here and you want to
start from the beginning the first two
minutes of this being live were set to
private so it's John and I trying to
figure out how to you know properly make
this work thank you to everyone who's
helped contribute in the super chat here
for us gonna just roll off everyone's
names like like a quick freestyle Aaron
and I'm not
Tiffany Hoffman awesome having 45 Mike
2p 15 Ali Cole Kelly Dave Waterhouse
Nick be ill Soto six ash here the master
Bruce DC Big O show yah and zero me out
thank you guys so much
we're showing our support much love to
everyone here and feel free to keep
leaving comments on this video and as
I'm doing this I'm trying to remember
how to end this stream so we might just
be here for 5 4 3 2 1